[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the Thursday
evening class we are you know games you
should know by heart and today I picked
this game that actually I didn't know
about this game until recently and
somebody mentioned this game it's a
glücksburg versus night off game and
it's called the Polish immortal you
probably heard of the immortal game and
this is the polishing most of this was
played in Poland in 1930
so Glucksberg is playing white and the
black is Miguel my Dorf and a very
strong chess grandmaster from Argentina
and he played f5d for a five and
immediately we see a sharp opening here
did you guys know this opening what's
the name of this opening I see several
hands here yes the Dutch defense okay
this is a very sharp opening when black
plays f5 he is aiming he is aiming for a
very you know interesting battle
basically he wants to go for a win three
four is a classical setup
I prefer 93 idea 93 Knight f6 Bishop g5
that's what I prefer to do but he played
c4 Knight f6 Knight c3 g6
so white is just trying to get the
species and here in my opinion you know
Bishop before is a better move in
general but the black was aiming for
this setup do you know what this set up
when you see this pawn structure is
called because it's got a name actually
it was a Dutch defense but it turned to
something else here
so I want to see if you know the name of
this structure here yes
Stonewall structure everybody if you're
not familiar with that just try to take
a look at this and memorize this the
pawns
c6 d v e6 a5 that's your Stonewall
structure okay when you see it it's like
this because you know black puts the
spots on the light squares to control
the very important efore square but
what's the drawback about this structure
can you see the little problems that the
structure creates a couple of hands here
ashish ashish is saying the bishop is
trap you mean the bishop doesn't have
many squares to go to okay that is a
possibility walls what oh there must be
something else as well here no the
bishop is trapped something else you can
mention here yes we can expand very good
yeah that's it what we call this pump
huh what do we call this pawn yes
backward pawn backward pump but so far I
don't see the main thing that you should
mention here I don't see that the main
thing that you haven't mentioned here in
the back yes aha the arc squares are
weak so in chess when you put a lot of
pants on light squares automatically
what's happening your dark squares
become weak so here I can point out
these squares can you see this squares
are weak dark score so more pants you
put on the light squares your dark
squares become weak if you put them on a
dark square then your light squares
become weak so that's the that's the
difference okay so you have to remember
that okay
c6 Bishop d3 Bishop d6 castles Castle so
this is all standard I don't like this
play for why we did Bishop being trapped
here like I'm not a big fan of the movie
3 I think it's C 3 is actually there's a
reserves maybe and do be a smooth sign
here because why would you play 3 here
and block your Bishop that's not a very
good idea so the better move here is
Bishop f4 absolutely Bishop g5 you don't
really want to play because you never
really want to take on at 6 because if
you take on f6 then his dark square is
going to become stronger so you want to
keep the bishop so you can take
advantage of the the weak dark squares
okay that is very very important for you
to remember
Bishop belongs on f4 here he played III
c6 Bishop d3 Bishop d6 castles castles
in 92 somewhat an interesting idea he
wants to bring the knight on f4 I
probably will have just played d3 with
the idea of who can tell me the idea of
this small b3 there are two ideas
actually behind it so I need you to tell
me the both ideas that this bit remove
will create
next I want to give you a couple of
minutes to think because this is I don't
want to rush rush you into finding the
moves just think of two ideas two plants
now this move d3 does I like this idea
which ideas I'm talking about here huh
that is excellent thinking right there
Bravo yeah you mentioned all both plants
are huge that's what you had in mind
okay okay the idea is be three of course
you want to put a bishop on b2 and then
at some point put tonight on a five and
a four dish pastry if you manage to do
that that might not be that easy because
he's going to walk we need seven he's
going to oppose that idea black doesn't
want to exchange the dark school bishops
here okay blacked out the word that to
happen so that's why you remember that
okay so he doesn't want that so but he
didn't play b3 so to be honest I'm not
familiar with his opponent Glucksberg I
don't know what how strong he was but so
you know if you had played if he got the
level two plane I Dorf
but probably you know strong player
maybe light an IM or something so he
played 92 here now black plays Knight be
d7 developing his knight and now the
point of this move is just to play
Knight f4 this is you know main idea to
go here and white makes a strange move
here for some reason he makes a very
dubious poke Knight g5 now question mark
and this is why I always mention loose
pieces you don't want to have loose
pieces when you play chess chess and now
the night on g5 is unprotected that
means you can try to do some kind of
tactics perhaps to try to win some
materials so try to see if you have
anything here like to play do you see a
combination a classical combination here
for black so let's see please let me do
you see it Bishop takes h2 excellent
excellent start the word how do we call
this sacrifice when they sacrifice the
bishop on h2 or on h7 what's the name of
the sacrifice Mario the Greek gift
remember Greek gift this type of
sacrifice when you take your bishop and
sacrifice for the H pawn on h2 or on h7
this has a name Greek gift perfect so we
couldn't take because you know for
pretty clear reason why Nagi forecheck
then it looks pretty it looks pretty
tough yeah you just get made it so and
one thing to remember if they sacrifice
the bishop a you cannot capture that
means you did something wrong that
should be something they know every time
they sacrifice you cannot capture them
in your position is not good otherwise
you have to you know play principle then
capture but here if you capture it's not
good okay but it's still unclear because
you know this is hanging so it's tricky
I mean black is better but not least so
anybody know this game from we have a
big audience here who is familiar with
this game except Ashish our she knows
this here who it know okay very good
choice then because I was I was worried
a little bit and that's why I wanted to
see where you guys but I'm glad that you
know very familiar with this so this
will be you will remember this game very
interesting okay
94 okay excellent idea activating the
night and gay
getting ready to go here and what is
your idea if I captured the knife pawn
here yeah and now you go check and clean
edge to me that's your idea okay check
and you go finish to my deck so so
obviously he couldn't take it so he
played f4 yeah he could he had an idea
to go here but if this happened what
would you do
I mean besides just a simple Bishop back
and you have extra pawn and a good
mating attack than anything else you
have for you see anything better Queen
f6 actually g3 I don't think this is
such a good idea sheesh because now here
King de - and I think you might regret
the fact that you didn't bring the
bishop back sometimes you have to just
show patience sometimes you show
patience you don't want to just rush
things in okay so here this would be not
so good because after you catch one you
get trapped so so here if it goes here
we would just bring the bishop back and
very comfortable
okay so f4 now
huh no no let's think let's think little
bit I don't want you to rush Quinny
eight what is your idea tell us
excellent thinking excellent thing and
Queenie eight transferring the Queen to
h5 and now threatening some Bishop check
and clear h2 ideas excellent job very
good now he goes jittery he's trying to
find a way to escape escape with his
King so when we choose a plan we do what
we stay with it you choose a plan you
stick with it
Queen h5 now he goes here very important
moment here if you make an inaccurate
move you might regret it
don't rush bishop g3 don't rush it's not
so simple
the walk is winning but question is how
black is winning but how what do you
have against Luke h1 do you have
something if it is rook h1 yes a black
knight we're here the bishop is
protecting unfortunately yeah that would
have been a great move but the bishop is
there so well Bishop d3 we just got a
calculate rook h1 and Bishop age who I
know but after this is little
questionable now the bishop on you for
who very nice very nice
excellent tactics yeah I probably miss
played it yeah okay that was excellent
ah okay no but I I mean I I can do
something because you kind of stuck here
I can do like you have something like
Queen g1 maybe ah maybe can I just do
this I got to make sure there's no
tactics you know but I think it looks
too cramped you know this is a pretty
unpleasant pin here you know very
unpleasant in
okay I mean
I don't see I don't see what we can do
here okay let's go back
so it goes here now important idea here
important idea needed here please please
raise your hands because I want to give
chance you know everybody so if you
think you have it please let me know yes
Bishop g5 did you calculate all the
captures there are three different
captures you have to calculate they're
not the two of them losses on the spot
so if ruk takes check pretty pretty
straightforward right checkmate right
there so he has to this this we don't
even have to worry about we got a
checkmate right here so he has to play
the move Knight you want that's the key
move to calculate because you let new
down a piece now if you don't come up
with the checkmate you might lose it
you will lose it actually here now
black to move okay what's idea yes
better a little bit better we need to go
for a four six equal yes can be won
you know but then she takes this yeah I
mean there's a lot of pause but but
maybe it's not so clear you know because
now I start coming in and I you go back
I start coming in this it's unclear we
should be three yeah but okay
now you're not winning there this I
don't know this is I'm not sure it is
the interesting about about this game is
now it looks like the talk is stalled
here and normally we just give up here
you know normally we just know when
before we go into this but normally we
just think okay maybe there's nothing I
can do but you're going to do something
here let's see give you a chance you
know this game right okay let's give a
chance to the students if they can find
it
not always you need to have a check
check check check to win sometimes you
need to have a little break you know in
the combination to get the pieces in in
the back
'if I've excellent yes you need to bring
some more pieces into the game
what is your threat here efore check is
the threat correct so it seems like here
this part needs to be captured it
doesn't look like there is another way
around it so it has to be captured which
happen what is the follow-up to because
you have to show good calculation before
you play this move
night which night does it matter or not
really okay so here has to take back by
the way I want to remind you it down to
pieces already so if somehow this attack
doesn't work we know what's going to
happen we're going to lose so so
ninety-five I hear 95 well no choice I
gotta go forward now he goes back yes
you have a repetition yes but the
question is this wouldn't be the
immortal yes if it was ended with
repetition it's gotta be something here
yes
f4 interesting braid now break now bring
the bishop into the game also along the
way you bring your rook into the game
whenever you're attacking in these
positions if you see your and have
enough forces you bring more forces into
the attack okay and that's what the
small f4 does you bring more pieces into
the attack your Bishop is now in a game
your rook is now in a game if you have
more forces in okay do you have a
question okay so now you want to take on
g3 and this is going to be pretty deadly
here so he has to capture this way why
does he have to capture this way if he
captured this way what do you have night
h4 that is checkmate perfect so he has
to take this way now
now I want you to raise your hand if you
see the mate the whole thing it is not
so easy it's several moves I mean three
moves with do you see the whole
combination here because one wrong move
right one wrong move like ninety five
check right King III and he's escaping
and we won't even be able to actually
draw this now he goes to the safety on
c3 and we might lose we might lose so
okay yes
what is it story Bishop g4 check she's
sacrificing that King takes because if
you go here I think yeah you even a
you're going to be losing a coin and
it's not going to be good okay you're
going to lose yeah but okay you lose
three three you lose that four I mean
you lose everything I mean we can
analyze if you want I mean check I mean
this there might have been other ways to
win actually but I mean this looks
pretty pretty crushing you know because
the king is still in the middle see you
don't want this shape you see the shape
that's a sign for you that things didn't
go well for you because your rook is
where your Bishop is based is struct so
so I have to take this one as well now
what are you going to do check now king
can I go to the H file because the Queen
is there so it has to take and now H
five after four minor pieces sacrifice
it style with the bishops sacrifice on
h2 then double Knight sacrifice only
five and a bishop sacrifice on G for the
game ends in 22 moves here with a move H
7 h 5 and that's the Polish immortal for
you
Glucksberg versus Nidal in 1930 so
remember if you just type polish
immortal in the search you will be able
to find this game and notes and maybe
even analysis actually by some other
players you know like like people who
are ready analyzed so that's very very
very nice game ok let's review this game
to make sure everybody here will
remember this game and then we're going
to move on to some very good endgame
studies that I have for you okay I will
play the move for white and let's see if
you remember all the moves for black f5
everybody know the name of this opening
Dutch defence Dutch defence ok so we
continue with this setup
and well what's the name of this
structure everybody stone wall right
everybody know Dutch stone wall okay
when you see this track
that Stonewall and what are the pluses
in this structure for white over black
and what are the minuses here - is the
dark squares are weak we have some
backward pawn on e6 perhaps and what's
the what's the edge that we have huh
efore square correct okay now what did
black play here
loose move every time you make a little
move there might be consequences and
here the consequence is Greek gift if it
takes Nagi 42 kanji Fraga now
f 428 this is a very nice idea this is
really clever
28 and clean goes on H 5 H 5 very nice
you choose the plot you stick with it
now 13 Queen h2 check right
if King takes Queen H to check if so
thus Queen h2 is very strong so he goes
only move Knight G 1 okay if I
threatening efore right now he takes
Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 he goes
here 96 check f4 absolutely f4 breaking
through now and you have 95 ideas and
Bishop g4 ideas after f4 is suddenly all
your pieces coming into play F file is
open your Bishop on siege so everything
is looking suddenly very very good for
you you have threads like F takes G 3
and Queen takes G 3 so he captures this
way Bishop g4 check he takes it 95 check
and h5 checkmate
excellent everybody that's the polish
immortal now we're going to do some
in-game studies ok and you probably if
you watch my lectures before you know I
like to do endgame studies so here we
will do a couple of very very nice
endgame studies for you it looks
completely hopeless but you never give
up yet you never give up even if you
have very small chances you never resign
that's what I tell my students never
resign until it's it's you until a
checkmate sort of yeah all right the
first position I have for you this is
your first position
Aashish can you
I should share knows other positions but
I'm not sure this is okay why is it wise
to play please here you can make notes
write down this position it's white to
clay and you need to find a way to make
a draw save this game can you do that
wise to play and make a draw
because you know material-wise its lost
I mean even if I Queens come off the
board you're just losing so you have to
take that opportunity that you have here
and try to make something out of this
opportunity out there how many of you do
studies for your training for your
training for your development as a chess
player to become stronger pledge a
couple of hands this was big part of the
Russian Soviet training this was big
part of my training a lot of my friends
you know so this was we always did a lot
of studies we don't people don't do as
much here in US but I think this is very
important training actually to do this
so in game studies okay this will help
you with your calculations your
creativity your endgame technique you
will always have ideas you know that you
see that you wouldn't think in other
because if you have just seen this
position you would probably think it's
just completely hopeless I mean it
doesn't look like you even have that
many checks you're down a bishop and
you're down two pawns queen h8 Queen h8
and if King d6
Queen d8 quintics did yeah king c6 and
we should be seven I mean you don't have
a bad shoulder you don't have prepared
to out there no you have to calculate
quite a lot here it's not so simple I
mean this studies are never simple it's
just sometimes you could see the idea
quickly but this one requires good
calculation yes Queen h2 f4 but also
have King de 5 - you had something you
have couple of checks there but I for
just stops everything I'll just seal the
deal did you calculate for motion
advance ok let's try
I don't wanna when I'm doing the studies
I prefer to give you a little bit more
time to think then try to go move by a
move because then we start losing the
effect of calculation you know if we
start doing move by move what happens we
just we just makes it very simple so
instead I want you to be able to do like
try to do it in your head a little bit
that's what I like to do you have to
take advantage of the opportunity where
his king and queen is that's very
important to do this
the king and queen ashish KO f4
excellent check all right let's try to
understand now what is black going to do
after f4 he has two ways we can capture
right first capture is with a king what
do you do then check
Queen f3 check queen h1 check if it goes
to f3 we're just going to repeat the
position and if we go check King g3
right and same thing right check and
same thing you're just going to go here
and going to be able to win make a draw
so now we understand if it takes with
the king how we're going to make a draw
now let's take a look at the eggs with
the Queen what will happen now this is
very important here because if you make
the incorrect move you're not going to
be able to win so you have to play the
correct move here yes Queen h8 correct
check now the good thing about this
check he cannot go back to here because
if he goes here what kind of tactic you
have and what we call this skewer right
skewer so he has to go here Queen a a
check EP goes here again we go check and
take and now if you go Sears Queen 8 4
check and you win the Queen
if he goes now here again you're going
to give the same cheque
Aashish you're trying to lose yeah you
have to make sure you don't give
incorrect check because you will just
throw away the whole thing you know one
incorrect move efficient it's over
so check now check if it goes to c4 now
you have a nice skewer again check and
taking this so it has to go here check
now if it goes to c4 you have a queen a4
check winning the Queen so you have to
go here
clean h1 it's amazing because this is
the only way you're going to be able to
draw because you give checks checks you
use all the corners you know it's such
an incredible idea you have to use all
the corners of the petition to be able
to give a checks so you go check check
check and you just go around to be able
to make a drawer there's nothing you can
do if black is still trying to win this
if he tries to win this yeah you're just
using all the corners to check to make a
draw everybody understand how this
position works so it's very important
you play the correct move immediately f4
that's the only way you can make a draw
here we're going to do one more okay no
pants on the board that makes a task
very difficult to win a position like
this because without any pawns that
means you don't have an opportunity to
exchange the Queen that's like having an
extra piece it's not going to really
help you so that's why you have to try
to come up with a different idea here
exchanging the Queens will not help you
so you have to do something else so
white to play and win let's see again I
want you to calculate couple of moves
and then we'll start discussing again a
few moves you have to calculate first
it's about six moves the solution at six
moves and white wins we need to start
checking here hint hint for you guys you
have to start checking the King this is
the King right this is our target
do we see a check the problem is our
King is open if he starts shaking us we
have no space to hide so we have to do
the first checking okay Queen b3
interesting but something forcing do you
see something more forcing yes can Queen
system that's a little bit more forcing
right check he's got only one squared
and it's easier for you to calculate
because it's got only one squared now
Queen eight five correct move check now
he's got two options if if it goes here
it check it check so you have to move
the King if it goes here check
checkmate perfect excellent and if he
goes here now
now the night checkmate comes in right
perfect the night fork and the check
comes in game is over the problem now
here is that he is not going to just
wait for you to do that he's going to go
here now he is going to go here he is
going to go thing to b7 now what can you
do here
now let's so what's the most is raise
your hand so I know who is saying the
rules so King sis
okay okay what is the move you excellent
choice
now he's got three squares to go to this
loses to which idea right skewer again
that's another skewer right so he has to
go here he is absolutely forced to go
there what else he can do don't rush
don't rush Queen b6 check he goes here
checkmate excellent I never want to
resign yet so it's going to go here
check and now I fish you got to raise
your hand I'll show you keep saying the
Moose so now we got to the position it
seems like we have a win here do you
guys see you win yes you Queen be it but
he goes King g7 I don't see I don't see
a clear cut here you got a lot of checks
but I don't know if it's going to need
to anything I don't want a lot of checks
the trick is sometimes in these
positions you want to make a quiet move
after after a series of checks you want
to make a quiet move
after all the checks sometimes we need
to pause and try to make a quiet move
yes absolutely kingly - correct
and now his king cannot move his King
cannot move he has to move the Queen but
suddenly he's got no squish - go - he's
got no good squares to go - and if he
goes away from the seven you got a
checkmate right here so and this squares
are occupied this is taken so it
difficult here now he occupies his only
escape Square and if that happens what
you're going to do Queen B 8 checkmate
excellent so by playing the move King
the - you're basically going to put him
into sucks rank everybody familiar with
Luxor Bank when opponent has no useful
moves anything he plays is going to make
his position it's worse it will worsen
his position
ok I want again yes sure sure where
where do you want all the way back I
just want to know like everything
ah Queen c7 yeah so yeah this is
interesting you're threatening checkmate
but the first of all I I can start
checking you so a lot of checking are
going on here yeah yeah as I mentioned
earlier your king doesn't have an escape
area like a shield because the king is
wide open it's a wide-open board and I'm
going to just give you so many checks in
fact you got to be careful one mistake
you're not even getting a half a point
here you know I've seen this come
happening people try to push too hard
and they blunder they go something like
this and suddenly they get skewered
we've seen this happen right we've all
seen this yes it happens it happens too
even strong players okay so so the main
thing I want you to when you go home you
have time I want you to maybe take a
look at this game again so so you will
remember the ideas Glucksberg versus
night off okay so that's a very
important game to look at it because you
know just the way he sacrificed all the
pieces and went for it so that's a very
good idea for you to do okay very good
and thank everybody for coming see you
next week
you
[Applause]
[Music]